today we're about to get our noses
pierced I'm [ __ ] psyched I can't wait
I have one of my nose here since I was
14 years old I've always seen piercings
as another form of self-expression all
in all I think piercings are absolutely
beautiful I told my mom about my
piercing last night and she was just
like silent [ __ ] scared I hate
needles so we better go do this before
change my mind I'm Bryan Keith Thompson
we're at body electric tattoo and
actually today is my 10 year anniversary
what we're gonna do first is clean your
nostril mark your nostril gears from
nostril
I'm not gonna surprise you so don't be
nervous we're gonna do this by the
numbers to relax don't let your mind win
just relax
give me a big giant deep breath oh man
oh yeah
deep breath oh and
[Music]
I love a
while I look crazy I am
Oh
oh yeah it's perfect I love it so much
and it was so painless I'm really happy
with it I think it's really cute soon as
I finished I looked at myself in the
mirror and I was it Oh looks like I've
always had a nose ring if he was
thinking about getting a piercing and it
actually means something to you then you
should definitely go for it
[Music]